-President Trump is demanding
an investigation
into last week's
anonymous op-ed warning
about his mental fitness
and slamming
the author of a new book
about the chaos
in his White House.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Applause ]
One of the weirdest aspects of
having Donald Trump as President
is the fact that every few
months or so,
people working at
the highest levels of government
have to put down everything
they're doing
and hunt for the anonymous mole
who just called
the President
a brain-dead moron.
Same thing over and over.
Someone calls the President
an idiot
or they call him a fifth grader
or they leak a transcript of him
telling the President of Mexico
he wants a piñata
for his birthday.
And then serious government
officials
and four-star generals have to
issue so many denials,
they start to sound like Shaggy.
-♪ It wasn't me ♪
[ Laughter ]
-And sure enough...
sure enough, the government is
once again
grinding to a halt
as the President demands
that the Attorney General use
actual law-enforcement resources
to investigate who wrote last
week's anonymous op-ed
in "The New York Times."
-President Trump is now
calling
on Attorney General
Jeff Sessions to track down
that unnamed senior official
behind that scathing
"New York Times" editorial.
-He sounds like Sherlock Holmes
after a concussion.
[ Laughter ]
[ As President Trump ]
My dear Watson,
we're going to find out
who the suspect is,
and where he is,
and what he did,
and who he what,
and why I where.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Trump apparently thinks
a crime might have been
committed
by whoever wrote the op-ed.
Yesterday White House counselor
Kellyanne Conway
was asked on CNN what exactly
that crime may be
and didn't have an answer.
-President Trump has said that
Jeff Sessions,
the Attorney General should be
investigating
who the author of the piece is
because of national
security reasons.
Is that a directive to DOJ
to investigate?
-From what I understand, there
can be an investigation
if there's criminal activity
perhaps.
-There doesn't appear to be any.
-I don't know that, and I don't
think you know that.
-What would the criminal
activity be?
-It really depends
on what else has been divulged
by an individual.
Anybody who would do this --
-But we read the op-ed.
There was nothing -- There are
no national secrets divulged.
-Anybody who would do this,
you don't know what else
they're saying.
-You think the person
broke the law?
-I don't know.
I have no idea.
-You think because he or she
wrote the op-ed,
he or she might have also
broken the law?
-I have really no idea,
nor do you.
-Yeah, we do.
We do because
we all read the op-ed.
There are no crimes in there.
It's called "I Am Part
of the Resistance
Inside the Trump
Administration,"
not "I Am Part
of the Resistance
Inside the Trump Administration,
and Also I Murdered a Guy."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
The fact is, calling
Donald Trump
an incompetent moron
is not a crime.
It's not even new information.
[ Laughter ]
And yet he's very obviously
freaked out by both
the anonymous op-ed and famed
journalist Bob Woodward's
blockbuster new book, "Fear."
He brought it up
repeatedly last week
and tweeted obsessively
about it again this morning.
>> "The Woodward book
is a joke," he tweeted...
-Please do that.
I would love to see you try
to write a book by yourself
without a ghost writer,
and I mean, a real book,
not one of your airport books
because I'm pretty sure
those books
have exactly one
word on each page.
[ Laughter ]
I'm talking an actual book
with chapters and an appendix.
Of course, if you told Trump
you need an appendix,
he'd probably say, "Fine,
just take Eric's."
[ Laughter ]
I got to say.
I got to say, I love imagining
Trump sitting at a typewriter
punching away at the keys
with his stubby meat paws.
He either types one finger
at a time grandpa-style
or with palms fully open like
he's playing Whac-A-Mole.
[ As President Trump ]
Sad.
[ Laughter ]
Exclamation point.
[ Normal voice ]
Trump has spent the last week
fixated on these
anonymous leaks
from inside his own White House
warning the country
that he's erratic and unstable.
So he's responding
by going on national TV
and acting erratic and unstable.
-The latest act of resistance
is the op-ed published
in the failing "New York Times"
by an "anomonous" --
really an "amonmos,"
gutless coward.
-Hmm.
Who -- who do you think it was?
Maybe it's the same person
who replaced your denture
adhesive with Silly Putty?
[ Laughter ]
[ As President Trump ]
Anonomomy.
[ Normal voice ] But it's not
surprising to me
that Trump wouldn't know how to
pronounce the word "anonymous"
since he's never done anything
anonymously in his life.
If he had been
the Gossip Girl,
he would have signed the notes
"XOXO, Donald J. Trump."
[ Laughter ]
But this...this is one
of the most surreal aspects
of the moment we're in.
The President of the United
States regularly has to go on TV
and try to convince people
that he's not out of his mind.
In fact, last week he just
straight up asked his supporters
to tell him that he's good
at his job.
-I beat all these Senators,
all these governors,
all these brilliant
political minds.
Then I beat the other side.
And then I listened.
"Is he competent?"
I think I'm pretty competent,
right?
Don't you think so?
-As a general rule,
it's never good
when you're the President
and you have to go on TV
and ask your supporters,
"Do you think I'm competent?"
If I was about to go under
and my surgeon said to me,
"Do you think I'm competent?"
I'd say, "You know what?
I'll keep the gallstones."
[ Laughter ]
Trump also argued that years
from now,
his speeches would be viewed
favorably by history,
drawing a parallel with
Abraham Lincoln
that made absolutely no sense.
-When Abraham Lincoln made
the Gettysburg Address speech,
the great speech,
do you know
he was ridiculed?
He was ridiculed.
He went up to Gettysburg
and he delivered that speech --
the Gettysburg Address --
and he was excoriated
by the fake news.
They had fake news.
He was excoriated.
They said it was a terrible,
terrible speech.
They said it was far too short.
It's not long.
Many of us know it by memory.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
You do not know the Gettysburg
Address by memory.
I doubt you know your own
address by memory.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ As President Trump ]
It's...
Yeah, three large pizzas.
It's a white house.
It's just a big, white house.
[ Normal voice ] So now Trump's
White House is engaged
in an aggressive attempt
to hunt down and expose
the leakers in his government
who think he's out of his mind
and they've reportedly
considered
some extreme measures.
-Advisors to the President
are considering
all their options,
including the idea
of a lie-detector test.
-You want Trump staffers
to take lie-detector tests?
That thing's going to start
freaking out
as soon as you get it
inside the building.
Bringing a lie-detector test
inside this White House
is like bringing a Geiger
counter to Chernobyl.
All right.
Let's start with you, Kellyanne.
[ Geiger counter clicking ]
No, uh, let's start with you,
John Kelly.
[ Geiger counter clicking ]
You know what? Let's just start
with the President.
[ Geiger counter clicking,
explosion ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a paranoid President
who's demanding investigations
of his critics.
If you were looking for
the Constitutional crisis,
it's here.
It's being aided and abetted
by people whose names
we don't even know,
people who are --
-Anomonous.
-This has been been
"A Closer Look."
[ Applause ]